No story is complete without a good kiss —
and a kiss done right, at the perfect moment,
can mark the definitive moment in a movie.
That goes doubly for last kisses, too. Whether
they're long or short, bittersweet or devastating,
these are the best last kisses in movie history.
Inevitably, many last kisses in the movies
tend to be tinged with a touch of tragedy,
and Ridley Scott's Gladiator takes that
rule to its heart-wrenching extreme.
In Gladiator, Hispano-Roman soldier
Maximus faithfully serves the Roman
Emperor Marcus Aurelius, who selects him
to be his heir over his own son, Commodus.
Romans being Romans, Commodus decides
to kill his father before the decision
becomes official. When Maximus refuses to serve
the new Emperor, Commodus has him arrested.
Maximus soon escapes, however, and rides home
to his wife and son — only to find that they and
everyone else on their farm have been killed by
Commodus' men. It's here that Maximus tearfully
kisses his wife's scorched feet before collapsing
in despair. He's then kidnapped by a slave trader,
and, well, the whole gladiator
part of the movie happens.
Compounded by Hans Zimmer and
Lisa Gerrard's powerful score,
this scene provides a rare glimpse of emotion in
a movie better known for its epic fight sequences.
It reminds the audience that, behind Maximus'
soldierly exterior, he's just a man who loves
his wife and son. It's also the moment
that sets up Gladiator's iconic ending,
in which a victorious Maximus finally
reunites with his family in the afterlife.
Everybody knew going in that Titanic was never
going to end well. Nonetheless, you still can't
help but get emotionally invested in the romance
between society girl Rose and broke artist Jack.
Jack and Rose's most famous kiss, of course,
is their full-blown make-out session on the
ship's bow, long before things go
wrong. But it's not their last. Now,
figuring out which of their kisses is technically
their last is actually a little tricky. Obviously,
Jack and Rose don't have a lot of time for PDAs
as they're trying to escape a sinking ship. Later,
however, after Jack perishes in
the icy waters of the Atlantic,
Rose kisses his frozen hands in a final
goodbye — and promises to never let go.
"I'll never let go. I promise."
Rose then immediately lets go. She does hold
onto his memory, though, which, in hindsight,
is probably what she meant. During the movie's
final scene, Jack and Rose reunite at last
on the Titanic's first-class staircase.
They're surrounded by other passengers,
who cheer when the couple kisses one last time.
Is this a dream? Is Rose in the afterlife?
The meaning of the scene is deliberately
vague, but watching these two characters
reunite after 83 years with a kiss for the
ages will thaw even the iciest of hearts.
Not all last kisses happen between lovers. Take
Thelma & Louise, for example. In this movie,
best friends Thelma and Louise leave the former's
controlling husband behind for a fun weekend on
the road. Instead, they end up killing a man who
attacks Thelma, going on the run, picking up a
drifter, robbing a convenience store, and blowing
up a truck. But the best final kiss in this movie
isn't between Thelma and her new drifter lover
J.D., or between Louise and her on/off boyfriend.
Parked by the Grand Canyon with a motorcade of
cops behind them, the two friends-on-the-run
decide to go out with a bang — and they
mark their final moments with a kiss.
Unlike many movie kisses between women, this
kiss is neither salacious nor played to titillate
straight male audience members. It's just a moment
of true love between two friends. In the 20th
anniversary edition Blu-ray commentary, Susan
Sarandon took credit for this moment, saying:
"I had mentioned to Geena
that I was going to kiss her,
but I don't think Ridley
[Scott, the director] knew."
Fortunately, Sarandon pulled it off —
and a moment of movie history was born.
In Moulin Rouge! the tragedy of the last kiss
between tragically impoverished writer Christian
and aspiring actress Satine is that it comes
in the wake of a major victory for the couple.
The pair have finally ousted Satine's controlling
patron, the Duke, and delivered their vibrant,
wild, Bohemian musical to La Belle Époque
Paris. But thanks to an opening scene featuring
a devastated Christian, the audience has known
all along that something is going to go wrong.
And by the time the movie's grand
musical finale comes to a close,
Satine is also well aware that she is
suffering from a fatal bout of consumption.
"I'm cold, I'm cold, I'm cold… Hold me."
As Christian slowly realizes what's
happening, he holds her, kissing her softly
as she begs him to tell their story. Their
final scene brings together the fantastical
Moulin Rouge! stylization with a sense
of heartbreakingly authentic human drama.
As writer and director Baz
Luhrmann told The Guardian:
"[It's about] the transition of youthful idealism
to when you realize that there are things bigger
than you — people die, some relationships
cannot be — and you are destroyed by that."
Theatre fans will tell you that William
Shakespeare wrote the ultimate final kiss
back in the late 16th century.
But some 400 years later,
master of stylistic drama Baz Luhrmann
decided to put a new spin on Shakespeare's
version with his film production of Romeo +
Juliet. The Shakespearean dialogue remained,
but the swords became guns, the costumes
were updated, and a fish tank, of all things,
played a prominent part in the iconic couple's
meet cute. Shakespeare suddenly became '90s cool,
thanks in large part to Leonardo DiCaprio and
Claire Danes, who breathed life into the iconic
star-crossed lovers... and then, of course, killed
them both off in the most brutal way possible.
The CliffNotes version of the ending is
that Romeo, believing that Juliet is dead,
breaks into her tomb, intending to kill
himself. Juliet, who is only sedated,
wakes up just as he downs a deadly poison.
"I'll kiss thy lips. Haply some poison
yet doth hang on them." and the kiss
Juliet then turns Romeo's gun on herself. This
morbid moment turns the hallmark of young love
into a deadly weapon, just as the couple's
forbidden love ultimately led to their doom.
Shakespeare in Love takes more
than a few liberties with history,
and doesn't shy away from playing with
some tongue-in-cheek humor. Still,
the love story at the heart of it
all feels absolutely authentic.
The wealthy Viola is prevented from acting on the
London stage by both her social status and gender.
So she dresses up as a man and lands
the starring role in a new play called
Ethel the Pirate's Daughter by some mediocre
playwright named Will Shakespeare. Shakespeare
soon falls in love with Viola, and the
two begin an affair after Shakespeare
figures out that his leading actor
and his crush are the same person.
He even starts writing the play that becomes
Romeo and Juliet, based on their relationship.
But these star-crossed lovers are doomed from
the start. Viola is engaged to evil Lord Wessex,
and they're planning on moving to Virginia. Even
though they marry on the morning of the play,
Viola rushes back to the theater.
Through various circumstances,
Shakespeare and Viola end up playing Romeo
and Juliet, respectively. But when the play
ends — to thunderous applause — they have to
say goodbye. Viola kisses Will one more time,
then leaves without looking back. It's a
devastating, unavoidable goodbye in which the
two lovers leading the story don't get what they
want — which seems apt, considering the context.
For such an epic love story, Cold Mountain doesn't
have many kissing scenes — but it does
make the few that happen really count.
Ada is a fancy Charleston lady who falls
for silent and sturdy country boy Inman,
when she and her father move to Cold Mountain,
North Carolina. In 1861, Inman goes to fight for
the Confederacy in the Civil War. The two kiss
passionately before he leaves, then spend the
next three years apart, only able to communicate
with each other through the letters they write.
After a ferocious battle, Inman abandons
the army and sets out on the long journey
home. The two are eventually, uh,
"reacquainted", but the next day,
Inman gets into a shootout with a Home Guardsman
who's been pursuing Ada. He kills the man but is
fatally wounded himself. Ada holds him as he
dies, kissing his forehead and comforting him.
By the time you get to Inman and Ada's last kiss,
you've seen the both of them go through so
much to reunite that it feels blisteringly
unfair that they don't get a happy ending.
Sadly, though, their ill-fated romance tells
the same story of countless lovers who have
been doomed by wartime and human cruelty.
Not many teens have a ghost as a best friend, but
in 1995's Casper, Kat is used to the supernatural,
thanks to her dad's paranormal investigations.
As a result, she meets the ghost Casper when
they move into his ancestral home, Whipstaff
Manor. Although their initial meeting is a
little awkward, Casper wins over Kat and her dad,
James. But there's more to it than that — Casper
has had a crush on Kat since even before they
met, having seen a news report about James' work.
Sadly, the whole being dead thing throws a
significant wrench in their would-be romance.
However, in the basement, Kat and Casper
conveniently discover the Lazarus machine,
which Casper's father built to bring his son
back to life. But there's only enough formula
for one ghost-to-human transformation, and when
James dies in an accident, Casper sacrifices his
shot at resurrection so that Kat doesn't have to
lose her dad. As thanks, Kat's mom returns from
the afterlife and makes Casper human... but
only for the night of Kat's Halloween party.
Casper dances with Kat, and they kiss, right as
he turns back into his ghost form. It's sweet,
it's sad, and it's also a little funny.
What more could you ask of a final kiss?
The sexiest kiss in 1990's Ghost obviously
happens during that famous pottery scene.
But the last kiss between Demi Moore's Molly
and Patrick Swayze's Sam is by far the most
emotionally resonant of the movie — and
may be one of the all-time greats, to boot.
After being killed by a mugger, Sam becomes a
ghost. You know, hence the name of the movie.
While he can see his girlfriend Molly,
she doesn't know he's there. Sam then
stumbles across a supposedly fake psychic,
Oda Mae, who can actually hear and see him.
Oda Mae tries to convince Molly that she's
communicating with Sam, but a grief-stricken
Molly is skeptical. Meanwhile, Sam learns to
move physical objects with his ghostly energy,
and eventually, he rescues Oda Mae and
Molly from the man who had him killed.
Suddenly, Molly can see and hear Sam, too. He
realizes that, now that he's saved her and avenged
his own death, he has to move to the afterlife.
So Sam and Molly say goodbye with a kiss.
"It's amazing, Molly. The love
inside… you take it with you."
Swayze and Moore nail the bittersweetness of this
final kiss. In fact, it was Swayze's audition for
this scene that convinced the previously skeptical
filmmakers to cast him, and Moore perfectly
balances her character's frankly understandable
sense of confusion, joy, and sadness. Altogether,
it just works. There's a reason this was the
biggest movie of the year in 1990, you know.
If there is a Movie Kisses Hall of
Fame — and there should be — The
Notebook definitely has a place in it,
thanks entirely to one particular scene.
Lumber mill worker Noah and heiress Allie
defy her family's attempts to tear them apart
and triumphantly reunite with a passionate
kiss in the middle of a summer rainstorm.
That moment won Ryan Gosling
and Rachel McAdams the coveted
MTV Movie Award for Best Kiss in 2005 and
immediately went down in cinema history.
But it's Noah and Allie's final kiss that's
the most powerful. Having grown old together,
they both come down with various illnesses
and are taken to the same hospital. Allie,
who can barely remember Noah, is in the
dementia ward, while Noah is in for a heart
attack. But Noah sneaks into Allie's
room, and she briefly recognizes him.
After the two decide that they want to pass
away together, they kiss one last time.
The kiss in the rain has all the
passion of a long-delayed young
romance. But the final kiss contains the
true love and understanding of a couple
who really lived up to their promise to love
each other until the end, no matter what.
James Bond is lucky in lust but never in love.
In 2006's Casino Royale, however, it looked like
the playboy spy had finally met his match, both
romantically and professionally, in Vesper Lynd.
"So as charming as you are, Mr. Bond, I will
be keeping my eye on our government's money,
and off your perfectly formed arse."
"You noticed."
The two make it through a dangerous plot involving
shady organizations, creepy villains, and an
eye-watering torture scene, and are rewarded for
it with a romantic vacation in Venice. Bond even
plans to resign from MI6... until he learns that
Vesper has betrayed him, having stolen the money
Bond won in a high-stakes poker game on behalf
of the people holding her former lover hostage.
When the deal goes bad, Vesper
is taken captive by bad guys,
and Bond manages to take them out, one-by-one.
But as the building they're in starts to sink,
Vesper locks herself in an elevator, and refuses
to let Bond save her. He's eventually able to
get her out and back to the surface, but his
kiss of life quickly turns into a kiss goodbye.
Now, Bond movies have had their fair share of
last kisses over the years, but this one is
particularly special. Bond's farewell to the one
woman he truly loved resonates well beyond the
end of the movie, and sets up the character's arc
for the rest of Daniel Craig's time in the role.
Otherwise known as Wonder Woman, Diana Prince
has had no experience kissing human men
when she and US pilot Steve Trevor first
meet. But the unlikely pair still pull
off a truly romantic final kiss —
before hero duty calls, of course.
After Wonder Woman has marched
through the No Man's Land of 1917
and liberated the village of Veld, a
well-deserved celebration is in order.
So Steve offers to teach her
how to dance like humans do.
"You're awfully close."
"That's what it's all about."
But although sparks fly, neither Steve nor Diana
can imagine living an ordinary life together.
They go to a hotel room in the village
and nervously kiss... and that's all the
audience gets to see. Sadly for Diana, the
war gets between them, and Steve ends up
leaving her in the middle of a battle — with
a declaration of love, but no goodbye kiss.
If you're the kind of person who
gets a kick out of watching the slow,
painful disintegration of a once-hopeful romance
that has long become tortured and twisted,
then boy is Blue Valentine the movie for you.
Cindy and Dean fall in love at second
sight when she's a pre-med student
and he's delivering furniture. When Cindy finds
out she's pregnant with her ex-boyfriend's child,
she and Dean get married. Five years later, their
relationship is cracking under his drinking,
their money worries, and her despondency. Despite
their best attempts at salvaging the relationship,
things only get worse from there.
Eventually, Cindy tells Dean they have to break
up, but he tries to convince her that they should
stay together. He walks over to her and hugs her,
even as Cindy tenses up in his arms, and kisses
her on the head. The physical contradiction
of his hug and her stiffness reflects the
simple and tragic fact that they don't fit
together emotionally anymore. What was once
a gesture of love becomes a difficult goodbye,
and the scene's closing moments, intercut with
footage from their wedding day, shows just how far
they've come from their hopeful, younger selves.
The lovers in 1945's Brief Encounter mostly
convey their electric chemistry through,
well, basically anything other than kissing. So
when they do finally smooch, sparks really sizzle.
Laura is a bored housewife with a kind
but dull husband in 1940s England.
Her weekly highlight is taking the
train to the nearby town of Milford.
Waiting at the Milford station one
day, she meets a charming doctor, Alec,
who's also married with kids. After accidentally
meeting again, they begin a covert relationship.
Eventually, after a few near-misses, the
couple decide they can't continue their
affair and spend one final day together. The
heart-wrenching twist is that they don't even
get a private goodbye. At their last meeting,
they're interrupted by one of Laura's friends.
Alec has to leave to catch his train, and all
he can do is squeeze Laura on the shoulder.
The final kiss of the movie takes place earlier,
when they're also interrupted by the arrival of
a friend. And even this was a brave move on the
filmmakers' part. Brief Encounter was considered
so scandalous because of its adultery
that it was initially banned in Ireland.
While movies today are freer to show kisses
— even adulterous kisses — this one is
all the more powerful for being a daring
expression of rule-breaking passion.
If there's one movie that best sums
up the burden of impossible love,
it's Casablanca. Grouchy American Rick Blaine is
keeping a low profile in Casablanca during World
War II when his long-lost love, Ilsa Lund, walks
into his gin joint... accompanied by her husband,
Czech Resistance leader Victor Lazlo. Rick hasn't
seen Ilsa since the previous summer, when they
fell in love in Paris, only for her to abandon
him suddenly. Now, she and Lazlo are trying to
reach America to escape the Nazis, and Rick has
the exit papers they need in order to get out.
Reunited and still very much in love, Ilsa and
Rick plan to use the papers to leave together.
But Rick has a change of heart, and
puts Lazlo and Ilsa on the plane,
knowing that Lazlo needs Ilsa to continue his
important work. Many people think that Rick
and Ilsa's last kiss happens at the airport, but
come on — that would have been kind of a giveaway
to her husband. The kiss actually happens at
Rick's apartment the night before, when Ilsa
declares her love for Rick at long last. Ilsa and
Rick then release all that pent-up longing in a
perfectly-shot, dramatically soundtracked kiss
— which, inevitably, proves to be their last.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.